Мої вітання, Україно!
Я — Лішенко Юрій Юрійович,
дизеліст-механік 25-тої Української
антарктичної експедиції
На станції «Академік Вернадський»
я буду займатись
обслуговуванням систем життєзабезпечення станції
та дизель-генераторними установками
Вони обладнані двигунами VOLVO PENTA D100
і були встановлені ще у 1980 році
Тобто вони відпрацювали вже 40 років
Зараз закуплені зберігаються тут, у Пунта Аренасі.
Нові дизель-генераторні станції, які обладнані
більш економічними, екологічними двигунами VOLVO PENTA D7 TA
Також вони обладнані сучасними системами управління контролю та безпеки
Сподіваємось, що все буде гаразд
Ми таки попадемо на станцію
Чекаємо на відправку!